madam deputy speaker with permission i'd
like to make a statement on the pandemic
the omicron variant is continuing to
spread here and around the world
according to the latest data there are
now 261 confirmed cases in england 71 in
scotland and four in wales bringing the
total number of confirmed cases across
the uk to 336
this includes cases with no links to
international travel so we can conclude
that there is now community transmission
across multiple regions of england
beyond our shores confirmed omricon
cases have now been reported in 52
countries with 11 countries that include
romania mexico and chile all reporting
their first cases this weekend
this is a global battle and we are
playing a leading role
on friday i spoke with the director
general of the world health organization
to share our findings so far and discuss
how we can work together to tackle this
common threat
we're learning more about this new
variant all the time
recent analysis from the uk health
security agency suggests that the window
between infection and infectiousness may
be shorter for the omicron variant than
for the delta variant
but we don't yet have a complete picture
of whether omucon causes more severe
disease or indeed how it interacts with
the vaccines and so we can't stay for
certain at this point whether omicron
has the potential to knock our
knock us off our road to recovery
madam deputy speaker we are leaving
nothing to chance
our strategy is to buy ourselves time
and to strengthen our defenses
while our world-leading scientists
assess this new variant and what it
means for our fight against kobe 19
and so today i'd like to update the
house on some of the latest measures
that we are taking
first we're taking balanced and
proportionate measures at the border to
slow the incursion of the new variant
from abroad
we've seen with previous new variants
how strong defenses at the border
combined with the capacity we've built
for genomic sequencing can give us the
best possible chance of identifying and
responding to new variants
this includes our travel red list
which allows us to react quickly through
targeted measures when the data shows
calls for concern
analysis from uk hsa shows that at least
21 omicron cases in england alone are
linked to travel from nigeria and
there's a strong indication that omicron
is present there
nigeria also has very strong travel
links with south africa and it's the
second most popular flight destination
from johannesburg
based on this evidence we've made the
decision to add nigeria to the travel
red list and this came into force at 4am
this morning
this means that
whoever
that anyone who's not a uk or irish
citizen or a uk resident who's been in
nigeria for the past
10 days will be refused entry
those who are they must isolate in a
government approved facility for 10 days
where they will take two pcr tests
i know that there's been a spike in
demand for these facilities due to the
rapid expansion of the red list and that
some people have experienced issues
returning home
however we are ramping up this capacity
as quickly as possible we've already
bought several new hotels on board in
the past few days and we expect to
double the number of rooms that are
available this week
madam deputy speaker
when this new variant is appearing in
more and more countries every day we
also need to look beyond the red list
and strengthen our measures for a wider
range of travelers to make sure they
give us the protection we need against
this potential threat
ukhsa's findings that omicron may have a
shorter window between infection and
infectiousness mean that pre-departure
testing could have a greater role to
play in identifying positive cases
before travel
as a result of this new data and the
greater spread of omicron across the
globe
from 4 a.m tomorrow anyone traveling to
the uk from countries that are not on
the red list must also show proof of a
negative pcr or lateral flow test
this applies to any vaccinated travelers
so whether you're vaccinated or
unvaccinated at anyone age 12 and above
this should take tests
they should take tests as soon as
possible but to when they depart but no
earlier than 48 hours before
i know that these measures of course
they will bring disruption and that they
will impact people's plans to spend time
with their loved ones especially over
this festive period
but we're taking this early action now
so we don't have to take tougher action
later on and so that we can take every
opportunity to prevent more cases from
arriving in our country
i like to reinforce to honourable
members that these are temporary
measures while we improve our
understanding of this new variant
we'll be reviewing these measures along
with other temporary measures that we've
announced and we will update the house
next week i firmly believe that whenever
we put in place
curbs on people's freedoms we must make
sure that they are absolutely necessary
and i can assure the house that we won't
keep these measures in place for a day
longer than we have to
second madam deputy speaker as well as
acting to slow the incursion of the
variant from abroad we're also
strengthening our vital defenses here at
home
late last week we had the brilliant news
that another new treatment has been
approved by the mhra after it was found
to have reduced hospitalization and
death in high-risk adults with
symptomatic covid19 by 79
another defense of course is our
vaccination program on saturday we
recorded almost 450 000 booster jobs in
a single day and yesterday we announced
that we'd hit the significant milestone
of 20 million booster doses and third
doses across the united kingdom
in the last week the uk booster program
has reached more people than the adult
population of greater manchester and we
are expanding this life-saving program
even further as part of our target of
offering all adults in england a covert
19 booster job by the end of january
to put this plan into action we'll be
recruiting 10 000 more paid vaccinators
we're also deploying about 350 military
personnel in england this week to
support the vaccine booster program and
there's already over 100 personnel in
deployed in scotland supporting their
vaccination efforts
we'll have over 1500 pharmacy sites
putting jabs into arms across england
along with new hospital hubs and new
vaccination centers
we're bolstering our booster program so
that we can protect as many people as
possible strengthening our collective
defenses as this virus goes on the
advanced this winter